ya le pregunto porque el consejo
nacional electoral ecuatoriano tardo 14
días en dar un resultado final y poder
conocer al candidato que se enfrentará
en la segunda vuelta con antes araus
buenos días y gracias por la invitación
efectivamente no hay una explicación
convincente de esa demora
lamentablemente durante el conteo de la
noche de las elecciones
hubo una enorme cantidad de actas que de
alguna manera se les llama hasta con
novedades en la que la ley permite o más
bien obliga a que se las vuelva a
recontar aparte para encontrar ciertas
inconsistencias errores o sospecha de
algún tipo de d
[Música]
errores básicamente y esas actas se
demoran o en ser recontadas debieron
haberla hecho rápidamente porque el país
quedó en se presentó una una polémica
una polémica política de alto tono entre
los dos candidatos que se disputaban
entrada a la segunda vuelta y con el
pedido de uno de ellos del señor ya q
pérez de que prácticamente se recorte en
todas las actas de todo el total de todo
el país el problema es que la ley no
permite eso hacerlo sería prácticamente
que no tener una segunda vuelta sino
hasta después de varios meses si usted
abre la urna de todo el país y vuelve a
contar la votación obviamente
hubo un acuerdo político entre los
candidatos más bien limitando el
reconteo de las actas en ciertas
provincias y aparentemente eso tampoco
tenemos asidero en assen la ley se y el
consejo lo que ha hecho es básicamente
proceder a hacer el anuncio de la
segunda vuelta y abrir la posibilidad
ahora sí de iniciar las impugnaciones
gracias del caso abogado general yo esa
disputa entre candidatos ya q pérez y
guillermo lasso el candidato pérez quedó
entonces en el tercer lugar según dijo
el consejo nacional electoral pero
también el denuncia como se también lo
decía que hubo irregularidades incluso
fraude electoral en esta primera vuelta
de las elecciones el pasado 7 de febrero
le pregunto en qué se basan las
denuncias de pérez y quema novia en qué
maniobra tiene para poder apelar estos
resultados
bueno mire lamentablemente el candidato
pérez no ha presentado realmente
impugnaciones de acuerdo con la ley y
digamos hasta
específicamente y los indicios muy
claros
lamentablemente digo porque esto crea
pues obviamente una atmósfera de dudas
simplemente decir que cree que porque no
ha entrado la segunda vuelta 'ipso
facto' se ha cometido un fraude
electoral básicamente parte del problema
radica que la noche de las elecciones la
presidenta del consejo nacional
electoral incurrió en un lamentable
error al dar por un hecho ya que el
señor pérez estaba segundo en las
elecciones cuando aún no terminaba del
conteo oficial
ese tipo de anuncios no se hace como
usted sabe cuando a los los márgenes de
aproximación entre dos candidaturas es
muy es muy estrecho y ese es lo que
estamos pasando ahora la consecuencia de
haber haberse precipitado a dar por
hecho ya que el señor pérez era el
segundo ahora abogado que podemos
esperar en la segunda vuelta del 11 de
abril estaríamos frente al triunfo del
corre y está andrés araujo guillermo
lasso tiene chance de finalmente
quedarse con la presidencia del país en
suspenso su tercer intento
es muy difícil predecir esto hace cuatro
años el señor lazo quedó segundo en la
primera vuelta algo parecido a lo que
está hoy en día y tenía en su contra en
la segunda vuelta electoral a todo el
gobierno del presidente correa
a la fuerza que hoy apoya el señor pérez
también apoyándolo al señor rain y
moreno y a pesar de eso prácticamente
quedó empatada a la elección para
algunos hubo un triunfo de lazo o
recordará quizá usted del apagón
electrónico que sufrió el ecuador por
varias horas el día de la segunda vuelta
electoral así que no está todo dicho es
un margen considerable pero no es
tampoco un margen irremontable